Continuing along through the grammar of words.
This time we're going to focus on the part of speech known as the verb.
We'll study a variety of properties that are grammatically marked on verbs in
many languages.
Let's start with person number and gender number in gender.
We've already discussed with nouns and they work similarly with verbs.
A verb might take an ending to represent a singular number versus a plural
number.
Consider the example in English he talks versus they talk.
Talks is marked in the singular and talk is unmarked or maybe marked with a zero
morpheme.
In the plural,
the verb is marked for number class and gender is sometimes marked on verbs to
there are languages like Hebrew,
Aramaic and Arabic.
The Semitic languages that distinguished gender in their verb formation person
is something we haven't covered yet.
Grammatical person actually refers to the distance of removal from the speaker,
so I'm talking to you.
You're the second person on the first person.
Somebody else.
That is neither me nor you will be the third person,
but person doesn't indicate number.
So if there's a group of us,
in other words,
if it's in the plural,
we are the first person.
You all are the second person and they are the third person plural.
It's not at all uncommon for languages to mark person grammatically on the verb.
In early modern English speakers said something like,
I say [inaudible] but he say it and they're the verb ending reflects the person.
If you're learning another Indo European language,
person number,
endings are common site.
Let's move on to tense aspect and mood tents is the time of the verb.
It's when the action takes place.
So verbs tense might indicate that it happened in the past such as I said versus
I say,
it might indicate that it happens in the future.
In English we do this pair frantically,
I will say rather than a future tense ending,
but the romance languages for example,
do have future tense endings.
So you say the day in Spanish,
in Italian [inaudible] in French [inaudible] there's an inflection and it shows
you that the action takes place in the future.
It's a future tense.
So the basic tenses past,
present and future.
Makes Sense.
Aspect refers not to win.
The action takes place,
but the flow of the action,
so something is done at a specific point in time.
If it has a definite start and ending point,
it's perfective.
If it does not have a definite start and ending point,
it would be imperfectly and there are a variety of other aspects we could talk
about.
For example,
the for quantitative
English distinguishes these [inaudible] so we have a progressive aspect.
I am going versus a perfective were simple aspect.
I go,
these are both present tense action so the tense doesn't change,
but the aspect does mood to some degree reflects the speakers attitude or
judgment about the action taking place.
Something that is happening would normally be put in the declarative or
indicative mood.
Those types of moods that indicate facts or just plain statements are often
known as WRAL has moods because they referenced something real.
Other moods are often called Erie Alice Moods.
This is just one way of categorizing moods.
Irrel his moods include hypothetical moods like the conditional and other moods
that might be a bit more emotional,
like the imperative mood.
So if I say go,
that's the imperative mood,
but if I just say you are going,
that's a declarative.
It's a statement of fact.
In one case I'm stating something that's unreal but wished for and in the other
case something that Israel,
another mood you will run into in European languages is the subjunctive and
that's a counterfactual mood that demonstrates that the action isn't necessarily
the case.
So for instance in English we can say if I were you with the subjunctive form of
the verb be,
we don't say I were outside of that subjunctive which is because the
counterfactual or hypothetical statement triggered the use of the subjunctive
mood.
The same thing would be set in any romance language
in many languages,
questions and negations are also moods in Japan.
The question and he must Scott can be answered with the negative Adema saying
which is marked with the suffix for the negative mood.
Another property of verbs is voice which details the relationship between the
action and those participating in the action.
The basic voices of active and passive active voice includes all of the examples
we've used for verbs so far.
If something is done that requires the passive voice,
the passive voice in English is formulated with B and a past participle.
But other languages do things differently.
You can compare Latin,
which actually tax on suffixes to the root to form a passive.
So for instance,
we have AML in the active I love,
but onward,
I am loved in the passive.
You can compare that to English I love versus I am loved where I am loved as a
pair of phostic construction,
as was the case with nouns.
We can consider all the various forms of a verb taking into account all of the
properties that those forms reflect.
And in doing so,
we conjugate the verb.
We can list all of the verbs,
various forms in a charter,
pick out a specific form based on the properties that we discussed.
That's called a conjugation.
I hope you're now comfortable with some of the basic terms that are used for
discussing the grammar verbs.
Next time we learn the basics of pronouns.